la terreur c'est fini les Syriens vont
partir les nouvelles affiches qui
moussent la candidature d'un Kemal
killiger
sont partout dans les rues
elle rivalise de propos nationalistes
avec un penchant xénophobe qui est mal
killite Daru avait déjà promis
l'expulsion des réfugiés syriens et
afghan en deux ans mais il surenchérit
maintenant avec des propos comme ceci
les frontières et l'honneur de ce pays
tu as ramené 10 millions de réfugiés
dans le pays je ne laisserai pas notre
patrie aux mains de ceux qui considèrent
les femmes comme des objets
il essaie de renverser cette identité
cardoane a réussi à coller à
l'opposition voulant que s'il l'emporte
il ne sera pas combattre le terrorisme
dit cette analyste proche de
[Musique]
l'oppositionniste le discours de
killingstar nous ne convainc pas il se
contredit sans arrêt
torchon le lendemain il dit qu'un
foulard c'est la liberté de culte il se
contredit quelle version de lui doit-on
croire pour laquelle je voterai de mon
t-il il va soutenir le président erdan
au deuxième tour à l'instar de sinanoan
l'homme qui est venu jouer les troubles
fêtes au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle a donné son appui au
président sortant reste maintenant à
voir le poids véritable de cette appui
beaucoup d'éthes qui ont voté pour
synanaan se disent aujourd'hui déçu
trahi
un étudiant universitaire a voté pour
sinano a nos premiers tours mais pour
lui impossible de voter pour le
dirigeant islamo conservateur et là il a
effacé la laïcité et la religion s'est
mêlée aux affaires de l'État dit-il ça
va à l'encontre de nos principes
fondateurs
d'urgence actuelle pour la Turquie croit
le jeune nationaliste ce sont les
étrangers qu'ils y voir débarquer au
pays sans aucun contrôle
ce sont les demandeurs d'asile et les
migrants illégaux on ne parle que des
Syriens dit-il mais ils ne sont pas les
seuls
en ce sens il rejoint la position du
Parti affaire le parti de la victoire
dont la plateforme est particulièrement
anti-immigration son chef fut mitos dag
qui était de l'alliance avec sinanoan
vient de donner son appui à Kemal
kilichta roglou parce qu'ils se sont
sentis entendus dit le numéro 2 du parti
on veut pas perdre notre pays
[Musique]
on est là
nous nous oubliez pas officiellement 5
millions d'étrangers vivent en Turquie
les réfugiés syriens comptent pour 3
millions 400 000 d'entre eux
de la victoire assure que les frontières
de la Turquie sont poruses au point
d'avoir laissé passer 13 millions
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière ou
pays des chiffres exagérés et un
discours raciste et xénophobe aux yeux
de leur détracteurs moi je pense pas que
on est xénophobes on a des crins on a
des soucis pour nos pays et s'il y a 13
millions d'étrangers dans notre pays je
pense que j'aurai le même façon
encore la victoire de l'opposition
possible dimanche autrement il se
console comme bien des
ultrasnationalistes aujourd'hui d'avoir
fait en sorte que des voix comme les
leurs résonnent plus fort que tout et
domine le discours dans ce dernier droit
de la campagne ici marie-eveda
Radio-Canada
Istanbul